in the wake of the first world war
Denmark was given this territory at
Germany's expense which is interesting
because during the war Denmark didn't do
anything it maintained its neutrality
throughout the entirety of the conflict
and never so much as fired a shot in
anger and given that generally speaking
territorial gains in Warfare are for
Nations that you know took part it seems
a bit odd so what gives why did Denmark
gain territory despite being neutral so
in order to understand why Denmark
received these lands in 1920 we have to
go back to the mid-19th century at this
time King Frederick VII of Denmark was
also the Duke of sleshvig Holstein and
laoenberg which the further south you
went became less Danish and more German
Frederick was childless and he did the
only thing that childless Kings aren't
supposed to do he died this led to a
succession crisis in the duchies and
Frederick's successor Christian the
knife passed a new Constitution which
began the slow process of unifying the
duchies with Denmark proper this upset
the prussians and austrians since they
alongside laoenberg and Holstein were
part of the German Confederation and
neither wanted to see two members ripped
away leaving them with only one option
discussion with each other about how
they were going to crush Denmark in a
war long story short Denmark lost and
Prussia in Austria took these lands
Austria had previously agreed to hold a
referendum about the Danish majority
areas joining Denmark but it never got
to do that this was because Prussia soon
went to war with Austria taking its
previous gains from Denmark before going
on to form Germany five years later soon
World War one and German defeat so how
did Denmark get these lands well during
the war Denmark had maintained its
neutrality whilst trying to appease some
German demands as they really didn't
feel like getting invaded the Anton
didn't mind this since the neutral
Denmark was more useful than a Danish
front being opened that said the Anton
powers specifically France wanted to
give Denmark sizable territorial
concessions after the war officially
this was because of their commitment to
self-determination the actual reason was
because they wanted to make sure that
Germany could never wage war on such a
scale ever again in fact after the war
was won the Anton's desire to punish
Germany caused tensions with Denmark
Danish delegates arrived at the
Versailles conference to ask for these
lands the ones which Austria had
promised to ref referendum on 50 years
prior this upset Britain and France who
pushed Denmark to take more the British
government demanded that Denmark take
all of schless fig whereas France wanted
the Danish border to stop here at the
kill Canal as you can guess this had
absolutely nothing to do with what
Denmark wanted or needed instead it was
to make sure that any future war against
Germany would be easier the Danish
government refused to Annex these lands
because the vast majority of the people
who lived there were German and thus it
thought that it would only cause issues
down the road with the new Germany there
was a lot of pressure on Denmark to take
these extra lands and it was only after
the Americans intervened on Denmark's
behalf that Britain and France backed
down in the end it was agreed that these
two areas would hold referenda on
joining Denmark Northern schleswig
agreed to join Denmark with three to one
voting for Union and Central freshvig
voted overwhelmingly to stay with
Germany and so with the voting done
Denmark Annex Northern later on in 1920
giving Denmark its current borders with
Germany much to the annoyance of France
and Britain I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons James
bisonet Kelly moneymaker corshow wolf
Jordan Longman Adam's daughter Jerry
lambdin Marcus Arsenal why in hockey
Spencer Lightfoot words about books
podcast Gustav Swann Captain psydog rod
D Martin commune boogly Wiggly Mrs ET
Marvin cassau Aaron the white Matthew
Shipley Alex Schwinn Maggie pasgowski
Anthony Beckett Max and flaudio the
Macaw Corey Turner spinning three plates
Coppertone Winston cayward Charles the
first and Scottish Trekkie